the Haeju a symbol of faith a sign of
modesty an expression of liberation for
some and oppression for others whatever
the motive for wearing it the headscarf
that covers a woman's hair and sometimes
her shoulders is now a common sight and
a changing Europe
home to a growing Muslim minority so
widespread is the wearing of the veil
that there are hijab adds hijab fashion
shows and hijab models but this is no
fleeting fashion statement Islam did not
invent the headscarf and not everyone
agrees that the Quran demands it but
many women view it as an obligation and
yet few garments produce such a visceral
reaction the hijab in all its iterations
has become a symbol upon which Muslims
and non-muslims attach their opinions on
religion politics and nationhood I
decide who I'm gonna show my body to who
I'm gonna show my hair to if I want to
wear it I'm gonna wear it if we you
about it
I'm sorry you have to deal with yourself
just pressure I just felt it from my dad
he didn't have to say anything to
understand the gulf between perceptions
of the veil and the emotions of those
who wear it we have to peer into the
complex identity of a generation of
Muslims born in Europe
why does a simple piece of clothing
store such heated debate
it is in France that the hijab generates
the most controversy the principle of
leyte enshrined into law in 1905 goes
further than merely separating church
and state the debate over the hijab
reached fever pitch in the late 1990s
the law was passed in 2004 forbidding
any visible sign of religious
affiliation and public schools it was
known as the veiled it is in this
environment that Sun dose a 32 year old
nurse whose parents emigrated to france
from tunisia had her awakening about
islam she lives in London now in large
part because she feels freer to wear her
hijab I took her back to Paris where her
journey towards the hijab started
when we grew up we live in France but we
are not very French but as I grew up
I've realized that I'm not Tunisians
like I don't fit the culture it is very
different it is part of my roots but I'm
definitely French in and it was a bit
almost like a shame to say no your
french were that means that you who sell
your soul somehow after her studies
Santos moved from her sheltered family
life in burgundy to Paris now she had a
job a flat and the freedom to really
explore her identity but the western
lifestyle failed to live up to her
expectations finally I reached there and
I am there and I can have the same
things and I can be the same way and
that took me about three years to
realize that well that can't be all
actually I can't really find happiness
so I started looking for a more personal
way I am still Western but there must be
something else
and so she turned inward in her search
for meaning but there was no lightning
bolt or definitive moment when she
decided to wear the hijab it happened
progressively she began to tie up her
hair more some days she wore a hairband
on other days a turban I've realized
that I started wearing the hijab even
before I said that okay I'm gonna wear
the hijab because the way I was covering
myself that is the hijab the hijab is
not only a veil it's obviously an
attitude maybe a way of thinking or
living wearing the headscarf may allow
some women to embrace their Muslim
identity but what happens when that
decision puts them in direct conflict
with the state and the wider society in
which they live sandesh worked as a
nurse in a public hospital when she
began the transition towards the hijab
at first colleagues asked quiet
questions then louder ones whether for
example she was turning into an
extremist I mean some questions were
very intrusive and some people wanted to
understand somehow I mean it's good that
people ask questions however when he
turns to the point that I feel like I'm
justifying myself and it's like oh
please people can you just let me wear
my hijab know if I want to worry I'm
gonna wear it if were you above it I'm
sorry you have to deal with yourself she
tried to find another job but it was not
easy employment agencies also asked why
she was covering her hair she moved to a
private hospital but it was no more
welcoming and she was told that the
headscarf was turning patients away that
was really really hard because at that
time as I lost my job I couldn't pay my
bill and I had to make a decision very
quickly
it made me grew up as well because I was
quite idealistic about France its
principles and although I mean obviously
I knew that wasn't perfect and
everything but to leave such an
injustice so deeply and so personally
that was a big hard Sun does the sister
Istrian is a video blogger she had her
own religious awakening she lives in
Paris without ever discussing it the
sisters began to wear the hee
around the same time it also happened to
be in the aftermath of the September
11th attacks that was a period of
religious awakening among Europe's
Muslim communities many perceived the
war against jihadis as a war against
Islam it was very hard my first daughter
was four months old so it was my first
baby I was it was very hard for me and I
remember Sunday came to visit me and I
opened the door I said oh you're wearing
a hijab - yes and I wasn't worrying
because I was in my place why I see that
this mystery and stuck to the more
fashionable turban she has her own way
of wearing the hijab there is a big
difference in the way that you approach
Islamic dress and the way that Saunders
approaches Islamic dress yes but once
again it's a it's her way of
interpreting her her choices and this is
my way of interpreting a job and my
fashion and yet for many women hair in
itself offers a sense of freedom - so
why hide it I consider my hair and all
the parts of my body as a privilege I
gave to someone and this is for me is
the the higher highest point of feminism
I decide who I'm gonna show my body to
who I'm gonna show my hair to this is my
body and I decide who I'm gonna show my
my body to for women like Saunders in
this rain the hijab is about control
control over their own bodies and yet
how does that reconcile with the more
discriminatory aspects of their religion
whether it's polygamy or inheritance
laws so this is the way I understand it
they are extremely little rules which
must be followed prayer fasting all the
rest is let's say you can do this like
that this is the way I understand the
Quran is that this is an option for you
we were in bar bets
Paris is famous North African food
market Saunders tells me she's concerned
about the
lack of options for France's minorities
she believes young Muslims are not
permitted to fully integrate into French
society and that is fueling hostility
towards their host nation whatever the
efforts that they put on it and so I
think especially young people now men
and women have decided to step back and
to say actually I maybe I don't want to
be with you maybe I don't want to be
like a white to be accepted I am French
today at this is a statement I will
decide who I am and who I want to be
this is the heart of the identity crisis
for this generation of European Muslims
their immigrant parents came to France
with personalities fully formed they on
the other hand have to reconcile
different identities we want to work and
we want this anyone but but also we want
to feel that we are women it's not
difficult to find Muslim women in France
who disagree with sunders and in one
Paris suburb a group of mothers are
battling against what they see as the
first signs of radicalization their
concerns have become more pressing
following a wave of terrorist attacks in
France these women call themselves
period de mer the brigade of the mothers
their leader is Nadia Medina a mother of
two who was born in France of Algerian
parents was or Buena de Gama in the
captive scans on kittredges reported
fuller no ceremony comes beaucoup free
to the discrimination yet it's well it
escaped we don't someday funkier there
as I found a murky world of him I do too
composite of alarbus Kony control I like
it a lot the fuel economy do lose your
diversity but stuff for sunders it's
about faith not ideology her attachment
to the hijab was so strong that she
chose the Asia over life in France
I always had the choice to remove my
hatred I mean this choice is real and I
deliberately didn't make this one I
thought about it but very simply I
thought Noah would have betrayed myself
she knew that she would miss her sister
and the kids but a new life in London
beckoned I found a way today to be in
peace and it's more an acceptance of
what I am and who I am so it's more like
keep finding or keep looking for peace
in the complexity of life
[Music]
son das knew no one when she arrived in
London in March 2015 she rented a room
in a house next she gave up nursing she
chose to try her hand at cupping an
ancient alternative therapy recommended
as a cure-all by the Prophet Mohammed
life may have been uncertain but here at
least she could wear the hijab freely I
didn't have to justify it I didn't have
to answer questions I could just do
whatever I want I wanted to do it I
could just be so that was a big big
difference
while the veil in France is tied up with
the high stakes politics of the state
the rest of Europe has a more relaxed
attitude society at large is more at
ease with the concept of it as a choice
in the UK I feel it's much more
straightforward that means that we are
here on a very economical level it's
like I mean you've got skills we've got
a need that is fine however you are
whatever what you look like I feel like
there is no personal feelings in the
process which changed everything this
more tolerant attitude traditionally
occurred across much of Europe where the
proportion of Muslims is projected to
double by 2030 that's the shift from
four to eight percent of the European
population
professor Dominic Michael Drake explains
the differences between European
countries I think you'd probably say
that most countries are closer to the
United Kingdom than they are to France
so in Germany for example with a very
significant Muslim immigrant population
the generally has a very strong legal
constitution that protects rights but
recently perceptions of the headscarf
have been changing earlier this year the
European Court of Justice upheld a
company's right to prevent employees
wearing the hijab at work though as
Dominic suggests concerns about the Asia
often mask
deeper issues it's about levels of
immigration about society changing about
cultures being taken over or drowned and
have a real feeling of concern about it
the threat of radicalization has
unsettled Muslim minorities and their
relationship with other communities
Manchester was hit by a horrific
terrorist attack in 2017 it killed 22
people at a concert hall Muslims in the
city say they have faced a backlash at
the urban sanctuary a Muslim
organization in Manchester a group of
women discussed their choices and how
the garment that was meant to protect
them from prying eyes now renders them
more visible strengthens my resolve in
wearing it because I thinkwell know I am
a Muslim I'm proud to be a Muslim and
just because there's some individuals
who were kind of exploiting that and
misrepresenting it why should I let go
of that for others it's not nearly so
clear-cut sophia a 22 year old daughter
of a muslim father has been wearing the
hijab since finishing high school she
put it on after a trip to her father's
homeland where she rediscovered
her heritage but pressure also played a
part she's never felt comfortable
wearing it and has wanted to take it off
ever since she asked us not to show her
face it was just pressure I just felt it
from my dad you didn't have to say
anything but it's that pressure that you
just feel that when you look at your dad
and then you get to that age and
whenever you go out without the
headscarf you feel very awkward and you
just feel as if were you wearing a
headscarf will just make your dad happy
so I did according to Sophia the hijab
is a subject of controversy even within
the Muslim community there are girls she
says who want to put it on but are
worried about what others will say and
those who want to take it off and worry
about their family's reaction if you
made that decision to put it on fair
enough I'm happy for you
but for a lot of women it doesn't work
out and for a lot of girls it doesn't
work out they just don't feel that
connection it's God going to judge me
because I'm not wearing it I was he
going to judge me because I treated that
person nice this is where I talk about
ignorance I read the Quran and nowhere
does it says cover your head and chapter
Lord it talks about all women covering
her breasts from one side to the other
so I think as long as you're covered
there's only just modestly I mean there
are girls who wear the headscarf but
they wear very tight clothing so clearly
it's not about the
let's go it's about the way you dress
and then there's a lot of cases of girls
taking it off now rebelling against the
parents in a really extreme way there's
a lot of issues but we're very quiet
about it and I don't think the Muslim
community is doing enough to tackle
issues like this
unlike Saunders Sophia's British
identity is a strong if not stronger
than her Arab Muslim identity yeah I do
see myself as British I think I have
more British values than I have Arab
values I did grow up in an Arab
household but because I grew up here and
my friends are mainly British or English
I feel like I belong here more why
shouldn't I integrate I think this is
the problem within communities they
don't want to integrate they don't want
to understand that the country they have
just come to which is England it's
Christian and they have different
lifestyles people just differently
because if you don't like the way people
live here and you don't either way
people dress here well sorry you can't
change it go back fearful of the
reaction in Manchester to a veiled girl
after the terrorist attack Sofia's
mother told her to remove the hijab
within a few days Sofia no longer wore
the headscarf both Sanders and Sofia
long for acceptance and a sense of
belonging in different ways to wear or
not to wear the hijab is tied up with
their identity and with what it means to
be a European Muslim what is clear is
that the hijab has created an identity
crisis for Europe itself there is no
hiding from it it is part of Europe's
story and is here to stay
stop hiding your face stop hiding your
eyes I mean we are here and we are
always here yeah whatever you like it or
not Europe
is changing the world is changing
[Music]